I've been waiting I've been watching
I've been sitting on this evidence
looking
for you to welcome you to a very spooky
month in the 10 million dollar Studio we
have a lot of spooky surprises for you
in store including some of the dumbest
Investments that will horrify you and
what better way to start than looking
back at Matt Damon's Immortal Words
which came out almost exactly a year
from today near Halloween fortune favors
the brave
foreign
I've been asking myself is
true does Fortune favor the brave I mean
let's be honest he does sound cool while
saying it but then again everything
sounds cool with cool music behind it it
doesn't make it true like take this for
example put the music behind it as I say
this giant frogs do exist
you see what I mean it sounds epic but
clearly it's nonsense obviously giant
frogs do not uh oh my gosh they actually
exist I can't believe it I mean it's
actually real maybe Matt Damon was right
all alone oh it's just a CGI frog I'm
sorry I'm sorry guys you guys know I
don't respect CGI one bad I mean I feel
like if you can't do it for real uh you
might be a fraud and it's making me
wonder whether Matt Damon was really
standing in front of Mars this whole
time or not so the question does still
remain is it true that fortune favors
the brave well I've run the numbers and
Matt Damon told 18 million people to get
into crypto.com last year on October
28th and if you had jumped into the
crypto.com uh crypto coin you'd be down
50 on that investment right now at the
same time if you had chosen to get in
the global crypto Market at all you'd be
down roughly 60 percent over the year
even if you had mistaken this crypto ad
for a job ad and applied to crypto.com
you have still been screwed since a huge
chunk of their Workforce has now been
let go with crypto.com reporting 5
layoffs inside sources then responded to
that and said they lied it was much
bigger and other reports suggest it was
more like 30 to 40 percent of their
Workforce either way this sucks for
anyone who's involved with crypto.com
and is a pretty big Fall From Grace from
that uh heroic swelling music of fortune
favors the brave but I don't want to
ignore the fact that nearly every Market
is hurting right now not just crypto
with the famously stable S P 500 down 20
so let's not sugarcoat things Fortune
isn't really favoring anyone right now
it's just hurting some people more than
others so maybe the quote here is
Fortune hurts the Brave the most in fact
what I find so funny about this quote
from Matt Damon isn't just that it's not
true now or that it wasn't true when he
said it it wasn't true even when it was
first recorded remember that Matt Damon
told us the origin of this quote with
that epic music behind him the four
simple words that have been whispered by
the Intrepid since the time of the
Romans well I actually looked up what
he's referring to he's
not a Roman called Pliny the Younger who
was writing about his uncle's Adventures
to get near a volcano eruption
apparently everybody thought it was too
dangerous and wanted to go back but his
uncle was Matt Damon's ancestor or
something and said fortune favors the
brave and everyone thought that that was
pretty cool so they sailed closer to the
volcano and then the uncle died that's
right the ending of the original story
is that the uncle was quote overcome by
sulfur fumes and died what a perfect
encapsulation to this dumpster fire
Fortune doesn't just favor the brave
sometimes Fortune affixiates them
horribly with sulfur fumes